your hair looks good man does it looks
okay it's been pushed back by my uh
looks good looks okay it's a wig I
bought it I wouldn't even care I bought
it from the estate of Lucille Ball
the only thing is that it it straps
around my chin with a little strap
that's the thing that always gives it
away sometimes it slides back like a
yamaka I wouldn't have it any other way
um okay so uh I mean let's focus I want
to get but I want to get before the show
yeah where you your first passion is
music and yeah Jazz yeah jazz in your
neck of the woods Berkeley College you
went to Berkeley College of Music which
is still I was there not too long ago
and I was walking around near the
Berkeley College music and everybody
there was so funny I saw a kid hustling
to class late and he was holding the
largest
um I don't know if what like cello case
yeah yeah yeah and I was just yeah and
running to class holding a giant 60
pound cello case that that dwarfed this
person yeah yeah I had an upright bass I
would bring the upright bass to class on
my head because I was so tired of
schlepping it conventional instrument
though the upright bass that's cool but
it is not a good uh career choice or
life choice so if I had a choice between
like and we'll say the goal was to make
a ton of money yeah hedge fund or
playing uh Jazz stand up base yeah what
do you think is the better way to go
well I think you know the answer to that
brother yeah okay and that's why I work
at a hedge fund now
I think it'd be great if it came out
that you and I co-founded a hedge fund
and it was just killing it but it was
very unethical oh yeah really like we
were doing really unethical stuff in
people Ponzi schemes yeah and people
were saying like I don't understand
Conor Brian Eric Andre team up but what
are they doing
we're buying lower income housing
evicting people
we're tearing it down and then we're
selling it to a nuclear power plant
[Music]
and it's got a name that isn't even it's
it's got some name like
stylex
but you know what's interesting and talk
about this that am I getting you off
track because you have a specific
question I don't I really don't are you
sure well it's mostly about financial
stuff do you want to know how much is in
my bank account I should do a show where
that's what it's all about let's get
down to it brother and we really crunch
it and then we have uh we have your
account and call in yes well okay no
he's land Rich he's got a lot of
properties but you know I would like us
to have this more liquidity and then we
really crunch it down because that's
what people want to know about you Aaron
yeah the comedy is not interesting to
people I agree no one watches you most
of your fan base I mean I think you
famously said your your fan base is like
college dudes and black skateboarders
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
like that's a perfect description that
is my demo this show is sponsored by
better help so I know you're uh very
busy yeah you've got twins yes twins who
are over two now they're gonna be two in
July it's very easy to find yourself
self doing things for other people or
trying to be really productive and get a
lot done and take care of everybody I
know you're a caretaking personality
yeah I am so are you and and what
happens sometimes is you'd realize I
haven't checked in on myself I have no
clue how I'm doing yeah I bring this up
because I'm a big believer in talk
therapy if you if you can find the right
fit right person and getting help it's
made a huge difference in my life yeah
in some ways I've been your therapist
over the years you have been you've been
and I and I think that you're if you
didn't want to pray I don't want to pay
someone so I figured if I could just
talk to you I'll just do it for free but
it is so it is important to talk to
someone if you're thinking of starting
therapy maybe give better help a try
here's what I like about better help
it's entirely online this didn't exist
back in the day when I was
maybe looking for someone to talk to and
it's such a smart way to get involved in
this process better help is designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule find more balance with
better help I really think this is a
terrific idea visit betterhelp.com Conan
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Kona and you know I
just moved here I moved back to New York
we're in New York City right now after
yeah after 15 years in L.A and I was
like I need to go to a neighborhood my
profile is a little bit higher than when
I was here last and homeless
what's like a quiet safe neighborhood
everyone will leave me alone the East
Village that's where none of my
demographic
will
and true and I was wrong you were wrong
I was dead well here's the thing when
you remember what I said about college
Bros and black skateboarders you were
wrong that's their that's their Mecca no
you need to be
you need to be in like living in Jackie
onassis's old neighborhood like on the
Upper East Side I was going to say the
same thing where everybody's uh and only
to generalize but I'm just going to say
there's a certain neighborhood where
most people are very old very white very
rich yeah and they probably don't watch
adult swim or they're gone they don't
watch Adults Swim
um they don't know who I am they think
I'm a very they think I'm a an actress
who's aging poorly and
they're like I Conan I loved you in tar
I'm like why did you know my name was
Conan then
um and they say like well I up
the joke uh and then we get real
deconstructed uh but like Julianne Moore
has been drinking
yeah
and more is getting people see me around
and go oh my gosh before Julianne Moore
what happened and then people come up to
her and say you were looking pretty
rough I saw you walking down the street
with Eric Andre no you're talking about
um are are all actors
completely psychotic and emotionally
disturbed is there have you ever met a
single actor who uh is like hey I'm
grounded that I go to therapy and uh
there's nothing wrong with me they're
all like every single actor I've ever
met
completely there's always one exception
that proves the rule you know one
there's one that's like a a nice yeah
person yeah Tom Hanks seems like a
normal person unless he's committing a
string of Serial crimes in the Pacific
Northwest that nobody knows about but
but you're right most people that get
into the Performing Arts not well and uh
and myself included we're not well I'm
not an actor but I'm not well you know
and so it's God should I start uh Zoloft
I have Zoloft in my medicine cabinet and
I'm just looking at it and I'm like
should I do another decade of crippling
anxiety and uh now so did you get the
prescription or did you stole it or you
found this
one man's trash is another man's trash
the expiration date it's like that's
when they really hear when they're
expired yeah it's from the first Bush
Administration the Elder bush
um those have just basically turned into
salt now they're not even a medication
anymore and they're delicious brother
they're like anchovies from Sicily
I like that they have no more no more
effect on your mental health but they
have a pretty good taste it enhances a
pizza or a salad